theoretically I have shorter talk so I
guess this might work out um for for the
last day of the talk or last Talk of the
day um okay so so I um wanted to kind of
tell you about this um paper that we
published with with Tallen G last year
on um exactly solving marginal map um I
guess the quer marginal map kind of came
up couple times during the
workshop um so the particular reason I
wanted to kind of tell you about uh this
solver approach is it has slightly a you
know different flavor than kind of the
the exact algorithm by like feedforward
evaluation that that we've seen um more
more at the
workshop so
um we've already seen this couple times
but just to just to um make sure that
we're all on the same page so to Define
uh marginal map basically the the query
is that um if you have a distribution
over set of variables X we want to find
um the state to state over over those
some set of Cur variables to maximize
the marginal probability and you could
do this with with some you know evidence
given um optionally doesn't matter too
much um really the idea is the the key
thing is that you you need to um you
want to maximize some marginal
probability so you need to sum out um
some lat variables or or some hidden
variables
okay so essentially this is kind of a
you can think of it as like a two layer
of queries you're trying to um compute
the map of some marginal
distribution so this makes it in in
general MP to the pp hard for graphical
models and so
on so now um let's consider the case
where our distribution uh P here is
actually given as a probabilistic
circuit
so just to um I'm sure this this is
probably like boring for you at this
point but just to make sure we
absolutely all on the same page right so
if if we if the circuit that's given is
smooth and decomposable we know that we
can compute uh marginal probabilities in
linear time just by feedforward
evaluation um and you can compute
marginals for any you know arbitrary
partial assignments to you know
arbitrary subset of your of your
variable and then if we additionally
have uh deterministic suum
nodes then we can also compute um map or
mp uh tractably so so if you are trying
to maximize over um all set of variables
in your uh circuit um you can do this
effectively with smooth decomposable and
and determin
Pie the problem is if even even um if we
can compute marginals and and map
tractably so even for smooth DEC
composable and deterministic circuits uh
Computing know marginal map Cy is is
still NP hard
okay and the the intuition of of why
that is is basically we we trying to
maximize um over some marginal
distribution so essentially we we need
this um we need the the circuit that's
going to represent that marginal
distribution to still be deterministic
which is in general not true if you're
given some deterministic circuit so how
we compute marginals is for instance
let's say your query variables are just
X1 and x2 in in this circuit over three
variables how you compute marginals is
just to you know replace all of these Le
nodes that you want to sell them out
with ones okay in this case they just
all get uh multiplied into one so you
can basically just disappear so in this
resulting circuit um now this is no
longer uh deterministic right so so if
you look at this sum node um for a value
you know of X2 so X if X2 is false um
both of these inputs to to that sub node
will be nonzero so this is no longer
deterministic and we cannot um just
linear time compute the marginal map
query for for this uh query
set
okay so um what can we
do well
um we can of course try to find the uh
structureal constraints the the circuit
constraints that will let us compute
marginal maap in linear time right and
we already saw um one example of that in
Reena talk where if you have you know
Endor or search um with a constrainted
pseudo tree basically if you have all
the um map variables or query variables
appearing at the top of your circuit um
then you can you can compute marginal
map exactly in linear
time um there's slightly general
definition that that basically just says
after you marginalize um out out some
variables the resulting circuit is
deterministic so you can just call it
like marginal determinism or or Q
determinism this is still you know very
hard to enforce um I think benju might
be telling you more about this on on so
so this property also shows up for
queries other than uh marginal map um
the point is to enforce these uh
constraints because once you enforce
them you can compute this MP hard query
in in linear time um actually trying to
do that is is hard your circuit might um
your circuit size might blow up you
might end up with exponential size and
also another point is that um if you
have a circuit you you enforce this
constraints for for particular marginal
map uh
query and then let's say you want to
compute another marginal map for a
different uh set of query variables then
you need to go through all that process
all over again you have to change your
circuit to to conform to that different
uh constraint right so that's that's
very uh expensive um so another
alternative is to keep the circuit as is
and then uh perform search on top of
them this is an optimization problem you
can you can uh do you can perform
search um so what what we um looked into
is essentially um in instead of kind of
in in one go uh enforcing this this hard
constraint we're trying to keep you know
upper and lower Bonds on the the
marginal that
probability um while transforming the
the circuit it ly and in the end we will
end up with a a circuit that actually um
that actually is tractable for Mar map
the kind of catch that that's hidden is
that you you may change the distribution
um as you're changing the circuit but
the guarantee is that we we will not
change the marginal map solution so for
this problem we can actually do this um
iterative transformation changing the
distributions because you'll still
output the uh right answer
okay so um as a starting point let's
first look at on what the easy way to
first get a lower and upper Bound for a
particular marginal map query um so in
in
the search for margin map paper that I
mentioned in the previous slide there
there's a essentially an algorithm to um
get an upper bound on the marginal map
through a single f forward pass this is
basically the same algorithm um that
would get you the the marginal La
solution if you started with a know
constrained circuit um if you just run
that algorithm on on a circuit that's
actually not tractable for marginal map
what you end up with is an upper bound
and and I'll actually show you a bit of
an example of that later um and then as
for lower bound because this is a
maximization problem you can just choose
any assignment cue um and then use its
marginal probability as a lower bound so
in in practice for example you can you
know compute the the full assignment MP
just take the assignments to the query
variables and that tends to work okay as
a as a um starting you know lower
round so the question is how can we um
tighten these bounds right how starting
from these how how can we you know make
them better and and the goal is to
tighten the bound until know both uh
they they converge to the exact marginal
Absolution so that's exactly what we're
going to do um by uh transforming the
the circuit eratively
so the main idea that that we use to um
come up with iterative um
transformation is to notice that um when
you're Computing the margin map uh
probability not all parts of the circuit
are actually
relevant so what do I mean um let's take
this example circuit um and then let's
say we're Computing this marginal
probability right so we have a circuit
over three variables uh Computing this
marginal probability uh given a partial
exam to two
variables so in this case only the the
circuit that are highlighted in blue um
is actually relevant so if you see um so
all all the other ones that are not
colored all the uh black edges will
either you know propagate zero or will
get multiplied with zero at at some
point so it doesn't actually contribute
anything to to this marginal probability
so for example um you're given you know
X1 is one X2 is zero so this one will
just devalue to zero so it's um not
relevant at all um over here you know
the these May evaluate to some something
non zero but then in this side because
X1 is um given as one it'll get
multiplied with zero so all of these
this uh subcircuit over here is also uh
Irrelevant for this particular U partial
assignment and for um for this
particular example circuit it turns out
that this uh assignment that we were
looking at is actually the the marginal
map solution right so which means um if
we were to get rid of any Edge that's um
not color that's um any any black Edge
that's not highlighted if you print
those it it's not going to actually
affect your marginal map solution right
so for example in an extreme case if we
just look at this uh blue uh colored
subcircuit and then ask for the U
marginal map um or as to compute
marginal map you get get get back the
same
answer so now the um question boils down
to can we actually efficiently identify
which of these edges we can um we can
prune can can we identify which of the
edges will be you know Irrelevant for
your marginal map
solution so for that what we're going to
do is um Define a bound on every Edge
that we say um if if this okay let me
just go through so for it every Edge
what we're going to say is
um what's the largest you know marginal
probability you can get from an
assignment that actually uses that
particular
Edge basically for for each Edge uh
connecting node and and n c um we're
going to define a bound that essentially
is an upper Bound for a different
marginal map query if you will where
you're trying to maximize the marginal
probability over a smaller set of uh
assignments where the that set is
defined as just the the partial
assignments that actually know activates
the edge meaning that actually uses that
actually propagate something non zero on
that
edge so in the um earlier example we
were looking at um so this um partial
partial assignment that we were looking
at um appears in this uh set C for all
the edges that are
uh highlighted in blue and then it it
will not appear in in the other edges
that are not
highlighted or another way of of looking
at it is let's say we were we're looking
at this um this set C for just this uh
orange edge here
right so so we're asking um which
assignments to variables X1 and X2 um
actually activate or or uses or uh this
Edge in this case that just corresponds
to setting um X1 to1 and uh value of X2
can can be either so so in in this Edge
we'll we'll um have these two partial
assignments appearing in that set and
the and the goal is to
um goal is to compute a bound that says
um that will return the um larger or
maximum Max
probability on this Edge so larger um
marginal probability between these two
assignments if we looking at this
particular
Edge so if we have such a such a bound
then given you know any lower bound on
your marginal that probability you can
say if if this bound does not uh exceed
that lower lower bound we can safely
prove that edge right because this just
says you know this is a lower bound on
your solution you're saying um assign
assignments that assignments that that
use that edge um is not going to have a
marginal probability larger than that
lower bound meaning none of those can be
a marginal Absolution right so we can
get rid of that
edge and we we show that um for um so if
your if your input is a smooth and
decomposable circuit we can compute
these Edge bounds for all edges in your
circuit um in a single feed forward and
then a backward pass so in linear
time give um like a high level idea of
of that you know found algorithm with
kind of an example and and uh pictures
essentially um we also talk about it
more formally you know offline if if uh
anyone's interested but basically um
what we'll do is first start with the um
feed forward algorithm that I mentioned
that will get you the the upper bound on
the marginal map
solution and um how it works is
essentially um you you identify these um
so okay here so the the setting is still
the same so so here let say the the
query variables are X1 and
X2 um so so now we're going to look at
the the um sub nodes and see which ones
are actually um CU deterministic you can
just think of them as like a decision
node on the on the query variable um so
if if um so for any any of those uh Su
nodes that that's split on a query
variable what we'll do is actually turn
that into a a Max
node so here um we choose the the max
between these two that's just 0.9 do the
same thing here so choose the maximum
between the two um and
then for for the other ones it's just
business as usual compute you know
products and and weighted thms so
compute the weighted THM here again and
then at the top here so this is another
uh Q determin Su node this is basically
a decision node on EXP one so at that
point we also um take the max between
here essentially take the max between
093 * 6 and 084 * point4 okay so this um
is our starting uh upper bound on the
marginal map
solution and then now what we'll do is
starting from that bound um go backwards
so top down in the circuit
um tightening the The Edge Bond so um
tighten the edge Bond every time we we
encounter this you know Q deterministic
or or decision node on the C
variable and sort of the the intuition
of what the bound is is trying to do is
um for example okay let me yeah for for
example if you are um trying to get the
edge bound on on this or on this Edge
right
here the what this value is trying to um
or what what this value will will give
you is essentially imagine um this Su
note only had that edge as an input so
imagine you know this Edge didn't exist
and then um say you you run the same
feed forward algorithm to get the upper
bound so in the previous example the
upper bound we chose here was coming
from this Edge so if you get rid of that
and then run the same upper bound or
feed forward upper bound algorithm
you're going to end up with a with a
smaller value because you're going to
propagate a value from another one that
was not chosen in the max so um so
that's kind of the intuition of of what
each of the edge bound is trying to say
is if you are forced to use that edge
what would the upper bound have have
been and um kind of the the key part of
the algorithm is in instead of actually
removing an edge and running the
feedforward algorithm and doing that
over and over again we can actually use
the the cache value from the previous
feedforward pass to um get that edge
Bound for all edges and in one
go so that's really um all that's
happening so if you don't see a you know
C deterministic sum you just kind of
propagate the values from from parent to
uh
children and then down here you know do
the same thing so see um on on this Edge
you can know tighten the Bound by
essentially um looking at the cache
values and and doing some subtraction um
of in you know in in a careful way that
they still guarantees you that that this
is an upper bound
um if we uh computed this Con uh Edge
bound and let's say you're you um are
using some some partial assignment to
give you a a lower bound on your module
map so now now you have the lower bound
and then you can look at the circuit and
say Al so so these two um bounds have
value smaller than the lower bound I can
get rid of it so make the make the
circuit uh slightly
smaller of course the um catch is this
backward pass isn't going to prune you
know every every Edge that you possi can
so this is not going to you know
magically solve marginal map in one go
so what we have to do is
um iterate between pruning the edges as
much as you can and then
um another transformation called split
basically which is trying to also um
introduce more Q deterministic sub nodes
which gives you more you know
opportunity to tighten your
bound and then split is nothing but
basically you know try to DEC
composition or introducing a decision
node so if you're splitting on on
variable X1 you just introduce this
decision node on on X1 and then connect
the subcircuits um Each of which are are
of conditioned on the two values of
X1 so every time you you introduce this
split at the root node that's going to
tighten um your your
bound and
in in this iterative approach we are
splitting on you know one variable at a
time after we split on all all of the
query variables then you end up with a
um basically you end up with the
constraint structure where you have the
all the map variables at the at the top
of the circuit right which is um the
case where we know we we get the exact
marginal map solution so you um
basically we know the number of
iteration is going to be at most the
number of uh query variables you
have
right so um kind of of course you know
this is still solving an and you know NP
hard problem even though in an iterative
way so the catch is every time you do
this split you may you know double the
size of the circuit right um but what we
saw in practice is in a lot of cases um
pruning actually gets rid of a lot a lot
of the parts of the circuit so even
though you may double the size in the
next of iteration you may prune a lot of
the um lot lot of parts of the circuit
so then you can know double decrease it
again double decrease it again so this
is kind of one example run of of the
iterative solver and this kind of looks
like a typical run really um so what we
see is you know here you start with SI
something like a little over like
8,000 um so initially if when we doing a
lot of splits in the variables we do see
that the circuit size increases but as
we continue and tighten the bound um we
can prune more and more parts of the
circuit and at the end what we actually
end up with is even smaller than what we
started
with and this is of a a you know visual
uh representation of of what's happening
in it iteration is starting from some
lower bound and upper bound and and
iteratively tighten tightening it until
we end up at the exact
solution so um yeah and and so we be
compared um
with um essentially a uh search based
solver for you know map and mp on on
some networks which are also smooth and
decomposable uh circuits
and especially on on these kind of
larger data sets we we saw that you know
the um search algorithm couldn't you
know uh converge it was essentially like
timing out and we could solve almost all
of those cases right so so at least on
this Benchmark pruning seems to work
well enough to keep the circuit from you
know blowing up beyond
control
okay um yeah so I I I'll conclude there
um so essentially yeah the main idea was
that we can do this iterative circuit
Transformations going back and forth
between pruning and splitting to um
tighten upper and lower bounds on your
modular map uh query right and and you
know even though each split might in the
worst case double the size of the
circuit um it seems like at least in and
The Benchmark with that we tried pruning
uh seems to work pretty pretty
effectively um although you know um it
would be nice if we can provide any
guarantees this was also using kind of a
humis stic that I you know came up with
you know seems to make sense intuitively
I just tried a few and seem to work well
um of course can can be improved
um yeah and just to mention
like um
presented this as a marginal map solver
of course we're starting um you can you
know give it a non-deterministic circuit
so you can solve you know for example MP
for some project works or marginal map
yeah all all all the same um and maybe
one one question is can we actually you
know generalize this approach to get
bounds for you know other queries that
also to require uh determinism to
computer rly on on a
circuit um
also going with the the a recurring
theme of the uh program can we um you
know
generalize can can we give it like a
semi- ring treatment here I think the um
one point is that to tighten these bonds
we needed to basically do subtraction to
tighten the the upper Bond going from
top to bottom um
but then these values it's so it's it's
not exact subtraction we need it's
really we need to find some value that
satisfies some inequality so maybe like
monus is okay um there are probably like
experts who can tell me here um yeah
think that's it thank
[Applause]
you hi uh thanks for the talk uh in your
experiment uh we can see that the lower
bound stabilizes very quickly is it an
artifact of the implementation or just
the example or that's so that's actually
an observation that I kept seeing
actually quite quite often so the lower
bound I was using is essentially what I
mentioned earlier of like Computing MP
and then reducing it to the uh query
variable
set that seems to give you a pretty good
um L bound at least like it yeah it does
seem to stabilize quite early I don't
have a good explanation for that I don't
know if that happen like Beyond this
benchmarks but it is actually something
we noticed um at least on on these
thanks uh yeah thanks nice work
uh does this carry over to continuous
PCS as well like if I have gaussin
leaves or whatnot yeah so um I think if
you're given ENT I think if you're given
the terministic circuit then then you
have like leaves with maybe like
truncated uh support in that case I
think you can use that to um introduce
these like Q deterministic nodes at the
top so I think you can use those to
split right
um
otherwise I think if you try and split
you yeah I need to think if if you run
into problems like renormalizing after
you like introduce like truncated you
know gions that didn't occur in in your
input circuit but at least for at least
for um if you're starting with a
deterministic circuit I think you can
pretty much um apply that okay and if I
start with something like gaussian
leaves then it's probably probably
doable but like a little bit finicky
right so yeah then you have to like
think about like how how I'm going to
split like how do I want to split the
support because you have to introduce
these um you have to
introduce some Q deterministic uh some
nodes at at some point right because
that's the only time you actually
tighten the
bounds can you say something about the
the data sets that you are using are
those graphical models are those circuit
what is the input what is the input so
so these were all like um uh discrete uh
variable data sets so the input to the
algorithm was basically we um took these
uh data sets and then learned a uh
smooth and decomposable in this case
actually I think structure decomposable
circuit so so we learned circuits and
then from that U you know starting from
the circuit we we uh uh run the search
and our so the input is a circuit input
is a circuit yeah and uh so and the data
set you are when you are learning the
circuit from the data set do you assume
structure or you learn both the
structure and the parameters we learn
both the structure and parameters from
data and you are guaranteed to have a
circuit that will be uh you you can uh
it's can be in memory so it's bound so
if it would was a graphical model not
necessarily you can have this as a
starting point right yeah that's true so
if you're starting from a graphical
model you know if you're trying to
compile exactly the the hard part might
be actually getting the circuit in this
case at least you're not compiling to a
constrained circuit so we just need
smoothness and decomposability so we
might be able to compile uh you know
more uh models than if you were um than
if you were to try to compile it into
like a constraint circuit okay thank you
and there just one more question when
you are comparing uh with a search
algorithm which search is this something
uh in the literature or you implemented
it yeah this is this is from like a some
product network uh literature so this is
a
um dat had different juristic based
search um for both you know MP and and
margin map on uh smooth and decomposable
PCs okay thank
you hi uh yes thanks for the talk uh
nice work um I my my question is if I
understand correctly you are you're
running a branch and bound so
one of your operations is a branch the
other is a boundary and then you put
them back into circuit which means you
can still do both things but keep them
in a single circuit uh my question is
why instead of just doing the branch and
B separately and then keep the M
circuits reducing as you keep doing the
branch and bound so we not explicitly
doing branch and bound so it's a little
weird to think about but so by splitting
um and then introducing another like
split note at the root and so on we're
kind of almost like building a search
tree like bottom up if you so what you
end up with at the end yeah you do end
up with something that looks like a
search tree but we're not really
explicitly doing sear I think it's very
explicit I mean this is just a branch
and bond right because you keep the two
new circuits so my question is why put
back in a circuit instead of keeping
them separately and let's say que them
to process uh my question is
isn't the same or you're getting
something by keeping them into a single
model I think what um
so I might be missing something we can
discuss yeah I think what we introduce
um there's a split split
um um notes we introduce at the top so
the ones that we introduced
I I mean really the main thing is
sometimes here down here yeah down then
down in the subcircuits you may have
like shared subcircuits right so you
don't have to like keep track of
different this is like keeping track of
like different branches in parallel but
also with like shared
subcircuit that
sense yeah
can a quick one have you tried those
comparison against psdd with
constrainted with
and and if so that the problem is that
the the circuit becomes too large or
just perform a
poly yeah usually the yeah the problem
is that it it does become too large um
for I mean if we're learning we can give
it a yeah yeah we can give it a
constraint V tree but then I mean so in
the learning part then usually the the
issue is that you um end up with
something that's like less expressive
you you um don't get you know you get
like lower likelihood on the particular
data if you're learning and then if
you're trying to compile then of course
yeah it the the compilation part go just
for my understanding but the constraint
is like the the Q variables are on one
side and the other variables is
something
okay other
questions yeah so following on the next
question so what are the queries do just
uh M map for each
variable so for your experiments what
are the queries oh oh for for these yeah
so we so here um basically this is kind
of the um percentage of uh query hidden
and
evidence P evidence and hidden variables
that we have so according to those uh
percentages we kind of randomly sample
um so for example we'll randomly sample
like 30% of the uh variables as the quer
query variables so so these are on you
know average on some random instances of
of marginal see and what happened for
that case that you didn't finish I see
there's a nine out of a bunch of there
there are a few that that we couldn't
finish um yeah so so there what's
happening is really the circuit does
blow up I
see any other
questions so I actually have a question
I think like The crucial step is
identifying the q deterministic s nodes
right
so um we kind I mean so partially we
kind of cheat that we are like
introducing these decision nodes at the
top and at the bottom um we have
something that can essentially find um
not all q deterministic but some Q
deterministic nodes even though maybe
they're not you know exactly decision
nodes so we have something in between
that's actually you can you can um do a
first you know pre linear time
preprocessing to designate those nodes
we assume that is somehow easy to do
right um yeah I mean if if they decision
though then we can definitely right find
them pretty easily and then also find
some extra ones but yeah if
you if your circuit is such that it's
very hard to find any Q determined
signal then what happens is until you
introduce um until you do enough splits
you basically wouldn't put anything
right
okay more questions